brain training games like this one claim
to improve your mental skills we know
that if you practice a game after time
you'll become better at it but do they
make us better at performing other
cognitive tasks in our day-to-day lives
in 2010 a study published in Nature
concluded they don't the team recruited
thousands of healthy young and
middle-aged people to regularly practice
online tasks designed to improve various
brain functions like memory planning and
reasoning sure enough people got better
at the trained tasks but the benefits
didn't transfer to skills they hadn't
trained but the volunteers were all
under 60 and such spring chickens may
not have much to gain now a new study
suggests older adults could gain from
playing computerized games in California
Adam ghazali and his team have found
brain training can improve some of the
cognitive functions that become worse
with age like short-term memory and
attention they've designed a game called
neuro racer players drive along a road
whilst responding to signs that appear
on screen every few seconds this tests
how well they can do two things at once
Wow I'm dangerous here this is Adams
team recruited a group of older adults
aged between 60 and 85 none of whom
regularly play video games
they had their brain activity measured
then they took neuro eraser home and
played it for 12 hours over the course
of a month then they came back to the
lab the team attached electrodes to a
head cap to monitor their brain activity
while they played the game again if I
may ask what's your age I'm 63 but I
noticed that I forget sometimes near a
race the players were better at
multitasking during the game compared to
a control group and is good at playing
the game as people in their twenties
playing for the first time
they performed just as well six months
later the team also noticed more
activity in the prefrontal cortex the
region of the brain involved in
controlling decisions while the subject
was playing the game they'd also become
better at retaining information for
short periods of time and of sustaining
their attention these brain skills
usually decline as we age although the
benefits of brain training in younger
age groups remain unclear the team think
a more challenging version of neuro
Racer could do the trick but in the over
60s this racy little number may yet hold
the key to revving up declining mental
skills
you